Arthur is in California hey Arthur
welcome to the show how can we help hey
Dave I am a did your financial piece a
eons and decades ago and became
dedicated to not using credit cards and
I am a small date grower group dates and
do farmers markets
I have resisted taking credit cards
because of the three and a half percent
that it cost me that's three and a half
percent it's a hundred percent profit
that's out of my pocket and also just
because I believe in the philosophy that
you guys teach which is not using credit
cards but increasingly I'm starting now
in this last year especially starting to
actually lose sales because people don't
have anything the plastic is there an
alternative to credit cards that doesn't
cost me three and a half percent and
where I am still protected against fraud
credit card you know you limited on
fraud at twenty five bucks but is there
something like that another vehicle that
we can use as far as a merchant yes yeah
that's what I'm making sure you're
talking about that side of the equation
yeah as far as a merchant I'm not aware
of one we take debit cards here at
Ramsey we do not take credit cards and
our service that we use allows us to do
that but we do pay the fee I don't
remember if it's three and a half on our
volume or not but on small volume it is
three three and a half so that's fairly
normal and that is a you know a lot of
our sales the vast majority of ourselves
are online so to not be able to take
plastic in the debit card form would put
us out of business we are it does cost
us business that we don't take credit
cards but we're willing to take that
because we tell people not to use credit
cards we're not in this but we're in
that the business of teaching about that
you're not so if you were to just get a
something like a square that pops into
your phone and you can just run a card
down it I don't
those are probably three three and a
half percent - yeah they're better but
the it's a very easy way in a farmers
market setting for you to take plastic
but you're gonna have the fee I don't
know of anything that is felis on the
merchant side you know Arthur I would
look at this as you're saying that it's
costing you sales right now would you
rather have zero percent or would you
rather have 97 percent of that sale and
give three percent is I mean what you're
getting is a convenience when you're
paying that commission to the the
merchant the card merchant is probably
worth it to get those additional sales
and I mean you've got to make a personal
decision I mean like Dave saying there
there's no way we can take credit cards
with what we teach but it's its core
Jermaine - exactly
you know this is how we teach people to
do it I don't know if you want to use
your business to enforce those same
principles or not but that's a personal
decision and we're not gonna beat you up
if you choose to do that well he's not
gonna be able to change their habits
anyway so you know why hope it doesn't
change their habits when we don't take
it either that's right but but it would
make us into hypocrites right exactly
that's different than if you're selling
strawberries that's right you know and
so or whatever he said dates on dates
okay or whatever so I'm if you're in the
restaurant business and you hate credit
card debt but you choose to continue to
accept credit cards that's not on it's
not inconsistent because you're not
putting people into debt there now what
you don't want to do in a business where
you accept financing of some kind if
you're against debt is to is to
encourage your responsibility or
participate any responsibility or or
subprime stuff and those kinds of things
I wouldn't ever tell you to do that but
in your case Arthur I don't think you're
being inconsistent you can you can do
whatever you want to do but I don't
think you're being inconsistent and
honestly I think I hear you're more
concerned about the three and a half
percent